en el Día Nacional de los pueblos
indígenas que en Chile es feriado desde
2021 el presidente Gabriel borics
presentó la comisión presidencial para
la paz y el entendimiento que pretende
buscar una solución al conflicto que
desde el siglo XIX enfrenta al Estado de
chile con el pueblo mapuche por la
restitución de las tierras ancestrales
que fueron arrebatadas por parte del
Estado en el siglo XIX
manifestó tener esperanza de que se
puedan establecer bases sólidas y
duraderas para solucionar este conflicto
de larga Data manifestó que el estado ha
realizado iniciativas pero que estas han
sido claramente insuficientes y también
citó ejemplos internacionales que
muestran que a través del entendimiento
y el diálogo se puede conseguir una
relación armónica con los pueblos
originarios esta será uno de los
objetivos de esta comisión integrada por
ocho miembros entre ellos parlamentarios
de la oposición y el oficialismo
representantes de sectores agrícolas y
también de las comunidades mapuches que
tienen además otra serie de objetivos
como sistematizar el estado actual
establecer Cuántas tierras se han
devuelto cuántas se pueden devolver
Cuántas quedan por devolver también
establecer canales de diálogo realizar
una serie de propuestas que busquen la
justicia para el pueblo mapuche y
también la reparación Para las víctimas
de la violencia y sobre todo dialogar
Establecer un diálogo y un entendimiento
profundo entre todas las partes que
incluyen a Víctimas de la violencia
representantes gremiales agrícolas
pueblos mapuches indígenas también
gobiernos locales y
regionales además de la ciudadanía en
general una ardua labor la que tiene
esta comisión cuyo trabajo final se
espera para el segundo semestre de 2024